et nous sommes maintenant avec mathilde
de paris cette candidate du
rassemblement national pour les
municipales à blois bonjour a plus joué
et merci d'être avec nous sur le plateau
de rtl france marine le pen ne cesse de
le répéter elle l'a redit hier lors du
lancement de la campagne du rm pour les
municipales l'âge pivot est une vaste
manipulation pour quelles raisons à
écouter en fait cet âge pivot il a été
là pour pouvoir négocier plus facilement
on a l'impression d'avoir une avancée
puisque aujourd'hui on nous avance on
nous annonce le retrait enfin le
soi-disant retraite cet aspect vos
puisque si on a un peu plus dans le
discours de d'edouard philippe on se
rend compte que c'est un retrait
temporaire en attendant la fameuse
conférence de financement qui va avoir
lieu
et en réalité il maintient que c'est
pour lui le seul moyen d'arriver à l'eal
équilibre du régime des retraites et
donc il y tient à cet âge pivot
tout comme il tient à annuler tous les
régimes spécifiques
donc c'est vraiment enfin pour moi c'est
un recul un fort recul pour mieux sauter
ensuite il faut pas s'y tromper c'est ce
que dit marine le pen l'âge pivot
n'existe que parce qu'il a vocation à
sauter il n'ya là donc aucun geste
d'ouverture de lapin d'edouard philippe
vis-à-vis des partenaires sociaux selon
vos noms puisque il a même affirmé
lui-même qu'il était prêt s'il n'y avait
pas donc de consensus d'accord trouvé
avant la fin du mois d'avril
il est prêt à passer donc la réforme par
ordonnance c'est pas sans rappeler la
loi elle comme il savait qu'il passera
de force
cette réforme sans l'avis des français
selon un sondage ifop publiée hier dans
le journal du dimanche 71% des français
interrogés elles se disent favorables à
la suppression des quarante deux régimes
spéciaux de retraite marine le pen
promettent de supprimer à la retraite à
points c'est l'arrivée au pouvoir en
2022 est ce que cela signifie que le
rassemblement national rétablira donc
ces régimes spéciaux s'il arrive au
pouvoir
alors il faut faire attention ce que
dans les réseaux sociaux il ya
énormément de choses aux patrons font il
ya des régimes spéciaux qui ont tout à
fait lieu d'être
parce qu'on sait bien que les carrières
ne sont pas les mêmes en fonction de cil
on est dans des bureaux tout au long de
sa carrière il est plus facile
effectivement de partir plus tard en
revanche on a des métiers extrêmement
peiné je pense particulièrement au btp
des personnes qui arrivent mais avant
d'être à la retraite dans des situations
désastreux elle se retrouve en en
capacité professionnelle
ces régimes spéciaux ils étaient là
finalement pour établir une certaine
justice
aujourd'hui on nous vend un système un
régime universel soit disant égalitaire
mais en réalité met tout le monde sur un
pied d'égalité alors que les carrières
ne sont pas les mêmes que chaque métier
a ses spécificités et la pénibilité est
à prendre en compte
et bien c'est profondément injuste que
préconise alors le rassemblement
national pour établir un système de
retraite qui soient pérennes
écoutez nous on avait émis l'idée
aujourd'hui vous aviez une cotisation
pour renflouer en fait la caisse
d'assurance maladie et on avait fait le
calcul comme quoi si au final on pouvait
récupérer maintenant qu'on a ré ré
atteint un certain équilibre
on pouvait récupérer cette cotisation au
profit des retraites
eh bien ça aurait été une bonne solution
de financement nous sommes ouverts à
trouver de nouvelles solutions et
d'ailleurs c'est en ce moment ce que
tout le monde essaie de trouver d'autres
solutions pour pouvoir financer
effectivement retrouvé l'équipe de ce
régime mais il faut pas oublier que
l'essentiel c'est de retrouver l'emploi
puisque sans emploi sans cotisants et
bien effectivement on a des régimes qui
ne sont pas viables et c'est l'essentiel
de notre travail en tant que politique
c'est de retrouver un emploi suffisant
pour pouvoir avoir suffisamment de
cotisants pour lire et relire retraite
et dans philippe propose donc désormais
après l annonce du retrait provisoire de
la juge prévost il propose que soit donc
mis en place vous l'évoquez une
conférence sur l'équilibré le
financement du système des retraites à
laquelle les partenaires sociaux sont
invités à participer à leur ado pour
mission cette conférence d'arrêter les
mesures qui permettront d'atteindre
l'équilibré financier en 2027
syndicats et patronat ont jusqu'à avril
pour faire leurs propositions et trouver
un autre moyen que l'âge pivot
d'équilibrer les comptes d'ici à 2027
est ce que c'est un bon calendrier
à écouter tout on le dit on en est
quasiment certain que c'est trop court
on aura pas de solution d'ici là donc en
réalité comme je vous le disais tout à
l'heure c'est une fausse reculade pour
passer en force finalement ce cette
réforme en disant qu' aucune proposition
n'a été apportée que de fait on n'a pas
le choix que d'aller vers quelque chose
qui se passe par ordonnancement est-ce
que vous pour vous on peut séparer la
question du financement
la réforme générale des retraites est ce
que ce sont deux points qui peuvent être
discutés
l'un à côté de l'autre je pense que la
question de financement est important
puisque évidemment aujourd'hui la
question de la réforme c'est parce que
justement on sait qu'aujourd'hui le
régime n'est pas viable
donc il faut il faut la prendre en
considération et on sait bien
qu'aujourd'hui justement avec les
concessions qui ont été faites au final
tout on est en train de dire que le ca
va avoir un coût faramineux et que du
coup ça ça finalement ça remis en
question cette cette réforme eux-mêmes
l'essence même de la réforme qui était
de faire des économies pour pouvoir
asseoir justement un régime qui a viable
il faut savoir arrêter une grève
edouard philippe l'a déclaré hier quelle
est votre position au rassemblement
national vous appelez au contraire à la
poursuite de la grève des manifestations
cette semaine écoutez nous nous appelons
les français à rester vigilant parce que
effectivement il ne faut pas se faire
endormir par les annonces d'edouard
philippe parce que comme je vous le
disais tout à l'heure
elles sont là uniquement pour justement
mettre fin au conflit parce que c'est
très très dévastateur pour le
gouvernement actuel en termes de
notoriété
donc il veut faire croire en fait fait
un effort de sa part alors qu'eux ils
n'ont pas l'intention de changer de cap
et il a bien bien bien maintenue
d'ailleurs edouard philippe
il est il est constant et ne veut pas
prendre la responsabilité d'avoir reculé
sur le sujet en un mot comment est ce
que vous voyez l'évolution de la
situation comment est ce que vous voyez
ces prochaines semaines et je pense que
ça va être extrêmement difficile et je
pense que le gouvernement va
va devoir et
arriver à un constat qu'effectivement on
n'a pas trouvé d'accord d'ici avril
et je ne sais pas si je pense que tout
le monde est déterminé à la grève je
pense que que les travailleurs ne se ne
vont pas se faire avoir ils ont bien
compris en fait l'enjeu de cette réforme
donc je pense que le mouvement va se
poursuivre et que le gouvernement je
vous dis à terme va faire passer de
force cette réforme et vous soutenez
donc les grévistes oui merci beaucoup
mathilde de paris ce candidat du
rassemblement national pour les
municipales de blois